the Senate has less than 18 hours to
avoid a government shutdown there is no
sign of an agreement as talks come down
to the wire the House voted last night
to fund the government for another four
weeks but Senate Democrats don't want
that deal they're actually holding out
for an extension of the daca program
protecting young immigrants brought in
illegally as children Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning what's
the prognosis well at this point Nora it
is a high-stakes game of who blinks
first with government funding held in
the balance Democrats say that GOP
stalling on the so-called dreamers has
left them with no choice but Republicans
accuse them of holding the entire
government hostage over one issue motion
to reconsider is laid upon the table in
a preview of what's to come all but six
House Democrats voted against the
funding bill keeping the government
those Senate Democrats say they have
more than enough votes to kill the bill
unless Republicans cut a quick deal on
daca we lurch from week to week day to
day month to month
this resolution kicks the can down the
road and gives us no reason to believe
that'll be any different the Senate's
Republican leader warned Democrats will
bear the blame if the government runs
out of money for the first time since
2013 they're prepared to shut down the
government over the issue of the illegal
immigration McConnell admitted the
president's shifting positions are
hampering daca talks we're interested
and what his views are and those have
not been made fully apparent yeah
the chaos has left nearly 700,000 doctor
recipients in legal limbo and now the
government's ability to function is in
limbo - how does this end there are
millions of government workers who are
pretty anxious right now and they should
be and the whole country should be and
that is why it is absolutely imperative
that the Republicans now do what they
have not done 80% of the American people
support dreamers let's negotiate let's
get an agreement Democrats and some
Republicans are now pushing for a
measure that would fund the government
just for a few days to give the two
sides time to hammer out an agreement on
daca but it is hard to see Gale how that
would make that much difference since
this issue has been sitting in
Congress's lap since last fall well I
got a lot of worried people this morning
thank you very much Nancy